If there's one thing Rick and Morty loves,
it's unorthodox crossover promotions.
The Adult Swim series has done a number of
unexpected ads for a variety of media.
They generally consist of the titular characters
not taking the promotion seriously and going
off on a tangent that makes you, the viewer,
question why whatever company they're promoting
thought the ad would be a good idea.
Like, for example, the Rick and Morty ad for
Alien: Covenant, which devolved into an argument
between Rick and Morty about, uhh… drinking
drugs.
"You know, I never thought I'd say this, but
thank God you drink all those drugs and alcohol,
y'know?"
"Morty, you don't drink drugs."
"Well, whatever.
I don't know.
I'm innocent."
Still, the ads must provide some kind of good
buzz, because a new, bizarre mashup has arrived:
Rick and Morty meets Death Stranding.
In the 30-second spot, Rick and Morty are
seen walking through an animated version of
the landscape of Death Stranding, the highly-anticipated
PS4 game developed by Kojima Productions.
Rick looks like his normal self, while Morty
is dressed like the protagonist from the soon-to-be-released
game — Norman Reedus' Sam Porter Bridges
– complete with a floating baby in a tank
on his chest.
Yeah, it's a weird game.
Rick remarks that Hideo Kojima — the writer,
director, designer, and producer of Death
Stranding – has enlisted their help to try
to repair the game's dystopian world.
"What are these ghosts?"
"Uh, those are the Death Stranding, Rick."
"Oh, OK, yeah…
I wasn't paying attention."
Eventually, the duo's attention turns to the
baby as they try and decipher its purpose.
Is it an upgrade?
Some sort of health potion?
In the end, they decide to take the only logical
action:
"Let's eat it!"
"We can't eat it.
It's a baby."
"Morty, what if it makes us run faster or
jump higher?"
".......OK, let's eat the baby."
Yeah, it's a seriously twisted ad for an equally
bonkers kind of video game.
At first glance, a Rick and Morty and Death
Stranding crossover may feel like an odd match.
After all, one is an animated comedy series
that doesn't take itself too seriously while
the other is a dramatic video game that takes
itself extremely seriously.
But when you think about it, these two properties
actually go together pretty well — and not
just because of their sci-fi connections.
Rather, it's because they're both really weird.
Rick and Morty is pretty mainstream.
It's probably the most popular Adult Swim
series ever, and it has one of the most dedicated
fanbases of any show currently on television.
Every time a new Rick and Morty season is
announced, it's basically treated like an
event, and few other shows can match the excitement
it generates.
With the series' popularity, it's easy to
forget just how strange Rick and Morty is.
This is a show that has turned its protagonist
into a pickle, featured a character named
Mr. Poopybutthole, and woven a complex serialized
narrative that involves a multiverse and lots
of nonsensical — but strangely believable
— sci-fi jargon.
Pretty much the only current, mainstream piece
of entertainment that surpasses Rick and Morty
in weirdness is Death Stranding.
Seemingly no one can adequately describe what
the game is about – its ludicrously complex
story involves a post-apocalyptic America,
invisible ghosts, babies in jars that can
spot said ghosts, and a delivery man who will
somehow save the world.
Plus, Conan O'Brien's in it?
Honestly, it sounds like a Rick and Morty
episode.
"That hood was threaded by the hand of my
cosplay partner.
Wear it, and you too can ride the river rapids
without fear."
As with any new piece of content that involves
Rick and Morty, the new Death Stranding ad
serves as a reminder that the long-anticipated
fourth season of Rick and Morty is just around
the corner.
The upcoming season was confirmed in May 2018,
when Adult Swim announced that an additional
70 episodes of the series had been ordered
— likely consisting of seven 10-episode
seasons.
It was another year before it was announced
when Rick and Morty season 4 would debut,
with the timeframe of November 2019 given.
Then in October 2019, the season's first full
trailer finally arrived... and revealed that
only five episodes were ready to go starting
in November, with no date given for when the
second half of season 4 might premiere.
Now, those first five episodes are nearly
here, and fans will undoubtedly be happy to
take what they can get.
The season's first episode, titled "Edge of
Tomorty: Rick Die Rickpeat," is set to debut
on Sunday, November 10.
The episode's title is a play on the Tom Cruise
action film Edge of Tomorrow: Live, Die, Repeat,
meaning it's possible the series may parody
the film as it parodied Mad Max in season
3's "Rickmancing the Stone."
Or maybe the episode will parody a movie that's
nothing like Edge of Tomorrow, since "Rickmancing
the Stone" had nothing to do with the film
Romancing the Stone.
Who knows!
All we can say for sure about Rick and Morty
season 4 is that we'll be able to watch it
very soon.
"Lab coat, rip off Doctor Strange."
Meanwhile, those interested in picking up
Death Stranding can do so when the game launches
just ahead of Rick and Morty season 4 on Friday,
November 8.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
games, cartoons, and more are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.